let's get to it uh from bs to the goat
uh
tom brady he now has seven super bowl
rings and he used to say chris if you
remember this
they would ask him what's your favorite
super bowl ring and he would say
the next one right the next one right
well now that he's got
seven and there's never a guarantee
there's gonna be a next one but with him
who knows yeah eight nine ten i mean may
as well finish out the set may as well
take care of both hands no no seriously
he's taking it's almost he's he's so
it's so
unreal and he's in the game so much i'm
not even joking
it's almost taking the luster of the
super bowl away like i i'm really i
think it does i think it adds to it i i
think it's not the super bowl without
tom brady
i mean i i don't mean it from that like
i yes it makes it awesome i i understand
that i don't mean it but just almost the
luster of like
you know the prestige of being there and
other quarterbacks like he so
smashed everybody out of the water every
now and then it's almost just like
there's nothing to even catch or look to
you good luck you got no chance sorry
yeah well it's like the celtics of what
the 50s and 60s
it's a standard that has now transcended
teams
it goes from patriots to patriots
buccaneers and i'm sure he'd love to get
a second one with the buccaneers
you get a second one with the buccaneers
and you've killed you've destroyed
you've decimated the argument
that it was more belichick than brady if
brady can go somewhere else
and win two rings in two three four
years there and i
look i'm not gonna hand him next year's
ring but here's the bottom line he was
asked
to rank his super bowl rings here's what
he had to say when it comes to
prioritizing
one through seven
it's great that's that's where i rank it
it's great it's been a great year
and uh incredibly i mean just fun i just
there's a lot of uh
you know i think in a unique way um
it was kind of like with the coronavirus
situation
and all the protocols it was really like
football for junkies you know
there was not really a lot of other
things to do other than show up to work
and play football
it was you know normally there's a lot
of things go along with playing football
so if you love football
you know this was a year to be a player
in the nfl because that's all it was it
was like football camp
with all your buddies year round so that
was i really enjoyed that part
okay he doesn't want to prioritize his
his reigns every
year is different every year is special
this one's special it's his first year
with tampa bay he was able to go all in
full
football football junkie not that he
wasn't one anyway
what would you say of his seventh super
bowl rings which is the one
the and and not well this ring is nicer
than this one i'm talking about what it
signifies which
ring would stand out to you um
to me it's either his fourth or fifth
super bowl win
it's the the seattle or the atlanta game
either way
the seattle game he was in an era of
it's deflategate he took the heir to the
footballs in the afc championship game
and had been a long time since they won
the super bowl and they were down by 10
points and you're going eh
you know tom brady's good now yeah in
the years before you know me i didn't
think he was
all that great leading up to that super
bowl this is why they drafted jimmy g
but it's that one because of the legion
of boom
it gets the monkey off the back we won
the super bowl or
hey it's the fifth one now you know i
think the the confidence in the fourth
helps him do what he did in the fifth
but i guess the fifth one is the one i
look at you pass all the quarterbacks
bradshaw joe montana and they were down
28 to three
and it was the year that he got
suspended for deflategate and all that
kind of crap too
so uh i think that one to me would be
the one that stands out at least
in my mind for brady i think there's
something to be said for the first one
14 sure underdogs against the rams
finding a way to beat the greatest
show-offs on turf i think that one would
stand out
and to me look i i i'm not going to let
you get by with saying he deflated
the footballs in the afc championship
game because the evidence
is conclusive he hasn't even denied it
himself mike he doesn't even deny it
i know but matt casey saying move on no
no it's he took him out
it's over all the evidence is there we
know he did no i mean
why because because robert kraft and the
patriots fox used it and like changed
the subject and everything
we don't have enough time i'm telling
you the raw numbers
as applied to the atmospheric conditions
i'm telling you
no i'm telling you here's my theory and
then i'll move on
my theory is the guy who regularly took
the air out of the footballs
because the officials locker room was
full of people watching over time of
packers
seahawks remember that game we talked
about it before the super but
that that he couldn't do what he
ordinarily did
so i don't know they it looks like they
pulled us off the air so he takes it
into
he takes it into the that bathroom
and he freaks out and he doesn't do it
that's my theory he takes the bag of
balls into the bathroom
and he's like i don't have enough time
to do this it's going to be too
conspicuous there's cameras out there
i'm just not going to do it today i
think that's what happened
okay no wait wait wait wait but i think
he went in there
he didn't do it he went in there and
took the air out we've never heard from
him before
innocent people don't destroy their cell
phones okay that just doesn't happen we
still haven't found
those guys and everything about it and
the colts balls stayed
above the legal limit that that's and
tom brady has yet to say i didn't do it
he makes comments going
i don't feel like i cheated i don't
think i did anything wrong
it's not as serious as isis those are
his comments
he doesn't even say no so stop stop
that's what it is
the fifth one to me the fifth one is the
most significant
because that's the season in which he
served the four game suspension
and that was really the moment where i
mean i i i was
i was thinking that he was going to win
that one and and do maybe walk away
in the longest yard and stick the
football into roger goodell's stomach
and say put them on
i really did and you know his wife was
pushing him i mean from
from the standpoint of dramatic moment
it gets
no more dramatic than capping off
that win down 28 to three right in the
season that you were suspended
and and and saying that's it i'm out i
got my five see you later and
you know he made the right move because
four years later he's got two more
and four years from now i don't know is
he gonna have two more
is he really gonna have more like do we
re
when does this end chris well mike i
mean you know
it's not going to end right now i mean
the damn team is good we just
we just talked about it when we talked
about it in week five how good they were
we've
we've we've said i mean it is a team
that's got no weak spot
and he's the quarterback and his only
weak spot is
protect him and if you protect him he'll
tear your ass apart still
so that's where he's still awesome
there's no doubt
brady is awesome listen yeah i'm just
butting it up
listen i don't like the deflategate
thing yeah i think he's guilty
and why i'm just i'm just wrapping it up
and i the reason i'm mad about it
more than anything is because he didn't
need to do it he's
awesome and he's tom brady that's why i
get bothered because i actually
root for the guy and i did not like that
aspect now other than that
man you know again you're never going to
hear me say he's the most talented
quarterback and the greatest from that
standpoint
but damn his arm never gets the credit
it deserves
the clutchness is the greatest clutch
quarterback i've ever seen in my life
maybe the greatest clutch sports athlete
i've ever seen in my life i could
certainly say that
and i think mike here's the thing that
jumps out to me more than anything
i i mean i don't even know how to really
say this and what the the perseverance
um the perseverance one to change your
game when you went through issues
and persevere and change it and become
better
to like where 2014 and on tom brady
is better than 2009 to 2013 tom brady
that's insane
and that is like the discipline the
stubbornness
and everything about the work ethic the
diet
where other quarterbacks go into man i'm
gonna drink some beers after the game
and i'm gonna take some time off and he
never does that
and that to me the obsessiveness to like
he said in tom vs time
you're gonna have to kill yourself to
beat me because i'm going to do
everything
and that to me is his greatness and just
will always be like the shining beacon
thing that i think of with tom brady
and remember he did that lengthy
interview with howard stern last
april-ish after he joined the tampa bay
buccaneers and
he was very candid about some of the
family
stress arising from him being so
obsessed with football i think this
whole tampa thing
has taken a lot of the steam
out of it and i think the issues of the
past
between tom brady and his wife as it
relates to
because there is an element of extreme
selfishness
that goes into making the focal point
of the entire family sure the fact that
that dad exercises x hours a day
this and dad won't go to chuck e
cheese's and dad won't you know
and and it all revolves around probably
a thousand times worse than what you
dealt with yeah when dad's the
centerpiece because he's the
professional athlete
and and they found they've they've found
peace
they found balance they found something
and that's why i think he's talking now
about playing past 45 that was part of
the bargain
you know well just bear with me until
i'm 45 and now i think they realize you
know we kind of like this we're kind of
used to it we've gotten used to it let's
keep doing it
yeah what he's doing is so rare and so
special and so unprecedented and will
never be repeated
i think that that the people around him
are all in with the idea that he's going
to stretch that rubber band as far as he
possibly can i i think so
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports